you got a new album coming out we do may  19th it's called back to us at yours if  you want it is the current single that's  out now and but yeah we're just thrilled  about we got a duet on there that we did  with Lauren Alaina and Chris Stapleton's  got a song on there  Shane Mooney from from Dana J so we're  really really excited about so may 19th  what was kind of inspiring you on this  record what are you singing about I  think what was inspiring us was the fact  that we had the chance to take our time  and do the exact music we felt  comfortable doing our label head Scott  Borchetta just said look there's no  pressure no deadlines you guys take your  time make sure you have the music right  first and foremost never really had that  freedom before there's always the  pressure of meeting a deadline turning a  record in so that was really nice to  just do it when we felt like when we  were inspired and when we felt like  doing  you